[Music]
[Applause]
in my industry we believe that images
can change the world okay when I Eve
with bright-eyed and bushy-tailed the
truth is that we know that the images
themselves don't change the world
but we were also aware that since the
beginning of photography images have
provoked reactions in people and those
reactions have caused change to happen
so let's begin with a group of images
might be extremely surprised if you
didn't recognize many or most of them
they're best described as iconic so
iconic perhaps they're cliches in fact
they're so well known that you might
even recognize them in a slightly or
somewhat different form but I think
we're looking for something more we're
looking for something more we're looking
for images that shine an uncompromising
light on crucial issues images that
transcend borders that transcend
religions images that provoke us to step
up and do something in other words to
act for this image you've all seen it
changed our view of the physical world
we had never seen our planet from this
perspective before many people credit a
lot of the birth of the environmental
movement to our seeing the planet like
this for the first time its smallness
its fragility forty years later
this group more than most are well aware
of the destructive power that our
species can wield over our environment
and at last we appear to be doing
something about it this destructive
power takes many different forms for
example these images taken by Brent's
terton in the Congo these gorillas were
murdered some would even say crucified
and unsurprisingly
they sparked international outrage most
recently we've been tragically reminded
of the destructive power of nature
itself with the recent earthquake in
Haiti but I think that is far worse is
man's destructive power over man samuel
pisar an Auschwitz survivor said and
I'll quote him the Holocaust teaches us
that nature
even in screwless moments is benign in
comparison with man when he loses his
moral compass and his reason he has
another kind of crucifixion the
horrifying images from Abu Ghraib as
well as the images from one Tanima had a
profound impact the publication of those
images as opposed to the images
themselves caused a government to change
its policies some would argue that it is
those images that did more to fuel the
insurgency in Iraq than virtually any
other single act furthermore those
images forever removed the so called
moral high-ground of the occupying
forces let's go back a little in the
1960's and 1970's the Vietnam War was
basically shown in America's living
rooms day-in day-out news photos brought
people face to face with the victims of
the war a little girl burned by napalm a
student killed by the National Guard at
Kent State University in Ohio during a
protest in fact these images became the
voices of protests themselves now images
have power to shed light of
understanding on suspicion ignorant and
in particular I've given a lot of talks
on this but I'll just show one image the
issue of hiv/aids in the 1980's the
stigmatization of people with the
disease was an enormous barrier to even
discussing or addressing it a simple act
in nineteen eighty seven of the most
famous woman in the world the Princess
of Wales touching an hiv/aids infected
baby did a little great deal especially
in Europe to stop that she better than
most knew the power of an image so when
we are confronted by a powerful image we
all have a choice we can look away or we
can address the image thankfully when
these photos appeared in The Guardian in
1998 they put a lot of focus and
attention and in the end a lot of money
towards the Sudan famine relief efforts
did the images change the world no but
they had a major impact images often
push us to question our core beliefs and
our responsibilities to each other we
all saw those images after Katrina and I
think for millions of people they had a
very strong impact and I think it's very
unlikely that they weren't far from the
minds of Americans when they went to
vote in
November 2008 unfortunately some very
important images are deemed too graphic
or disturbing for us to see them
I'll show you one photo here and it's a
photo by Eugene Richards of an Iraq war
veteran from an extraordinary piece of
work which has never been published
called war is personal but images don't
need to be graphic in order to remind us
of the tragedy of war John Moore set up
this photo at Arlington Cemetery
after all the tense moments of conflict
in all the conflict zones of the world
there's one photograph from a much
quieter place that haunts me still much
more than the others Ansel Adams said
and I'm going to disagree with him
you don't take a photograph you make it
in my view it's not the photographer who
makes the photo it's you we bring to
each image our own values our own belief
systems and as a result of that the
image resonates with us my company has
70 million images I have one image in my
office here it is I hope that the next
time you see an image that sparks
something in you you'll better
understand why and I know that speaking
to this audience
you'll definitely do something about it
and thank you to all the photographers
[Applause]
[Music]
traffic is a global epidemic u.s.
traffic is creating 45 percent of the
world's air pollution in the UK time
wasted in traffic costs 20 billion a
year would you pay for cleaner air and a
faster commute Stockholm put it to a
vote I voted for it yes
they voted for it I vote for it we're
not old enough to know we have to do
something in stock on cue improve the
environment and to get a better flow in
the traffic we're put a price on taking
your car into the central parts of stock
on and we call that congestion charges
if you start a system like this and it
doesn't work on the first day then you
will be in big trouble
it must be perfect from day one there
are 18 empty gates to the city each is
equipped with cameras pictures are taken
of the rear and front license plates
these pictures are sent to a central
system that identifies the license
plates and makes sure that the right
person pays to the right passages one of
the obstacles we overcame was the OCR
the optical character reading of the
license plate
we went out IBM's global organization
and the Orang dissenters and find a very
good software we could use and we
managed to implement it in two months
time this is the heart of the system
rule images and passages are being
processed over nine to nine percent of
all pictures are correctly identified
so it's nice this is how it should be
all the time
behind me you can see the traffic and
the clock is 6:00 p.m.
before we have the congestion charge in
the traffic was queuing up at this time
of the day I think it's a good idea
because I think that we should take care
of the environment in the city the
traffic went down with about 22 percent
and the air pollution was about 14
percent better it's a huge international
interest from different part of the
world from the United States from Latin
America from China and it's really
pressure to tell people not what we are
planning to do what what we actually
have done in Stockholm I voted for it
yes I did not my husband
so but I did I think he is not thinking
like me for the future I'm thinking for
the children and the grandchildren
[Music]